[Music]
this week on
forward policy outputs result from
political inputs right and so if you
want to make things better it has to be
in the interest of that politician to do
so and then we did Uber the same people
who don't know who their state senator
is they never vote in a city council
primary were taking the time to advocate
for us because a it was something they
cared about and B we made it really easy
right you can do it right from the app
and so when that happened we're thinking
like holy if people could vote this
way maybe turn would be a lot higher and
then over the succeeding years cloud and
blockchain Technology both got better
and better we have to sort of get more
and more people voting and the only
election that really matters is the
primary because of Jerry mandering and
the only way I think to increase primary
turnout at scale is to let people do it
securely on their
[Music]
phones it is is my pleasure to Welcome
to the podcast the founder and CEO of
Tusk Ventures but more importantly a
multitime author political strategist uh
a dear friend of mine Bradley Tusk
welcome to the podcast Bradley thanks
for having me on so Bradley we're going
to get to your new novel obvious in
hindsight which I got to say I enjoyed
the heck out of but in order for someone
to understand this novel they have to
understand a little bit about you your
journey you got a crazy Journey you
started as like a normal guy yeah well
I'm sure my parents and sister would not
quite agree with the normal uh ever but
um but yeah I mean I started in one
industry which it's almost kind of the
inverse of you a little bit right like I
started in politics and then went into
teac and then started writing you
started intact started writing then went
into politics wow man the anti me yeah I
don't know neither one's better or worse
but but you know I think part of the
reason that we like like each other is
cuz we have a lot of similar experiences
we definitely have a lot of similar
experiences I got to say you're the Envy
of just about every lawyer I know in
terms of uh the the uh progression of
your career so people would want to know
how the heck do you go from being a
lawyer in politics to a very very
successful venture capitalist yeah so
the first thing is while I am
technically a member of the New York Bar
I've never actually practice law so the
best way to be a successful
non-practicing lawyer is to not practice
law that's number one
take notes everyone so I had sort of
three big jobs in in politics uh the
most important one to me was um ronning
Mike blumberg's mayoral campaign in 2009
and then I also worked for Mike uh when
he was mayor um I was the Deputy
Governor of Illinois for four years ran
the state's operations legislation uh
budget Communications and operations a
really crazy job because I worked for a
uh sociopath Nam Rob Lovich uh and it
was a very interesting four years um and
then two kind of crazy crazy years on
Capitol Hill as Chuck Schumer's
communications director which is
considered usually at the hardest
because Chuck is the most press hungry
member of Congress um being his press
guy is I considered the hardest job in
Washington until Trump showed up and
then being anywhere any job for Trump is
harder than working for jck but those
three things plus I had a few other jobs
in politics and then started my first
company the Consulting for Cai
strategies in
2010 and it it runs big campaigns for
big companies so you're Walmart you're
trying to open up stores in form ma
downtowns you've got Union issues zoning
issues Community issues we figure all
that stuff out and I'm sitting in a
meeting in early 2011 and a friend of
mine Kevin Chiki who I think you know
Kevin calls me says hey there's this guy
with a small Transportation startup he's
having some regulatory problems would
you mind talking to him sure whatever
Kevin asked me to do I always say sure
um but I become Uber's first political
uh adviser that day and then I get
really lucky when Travis calls back and
says listen I can't afford your fee
would you take Equity I didn't even know
what Equity meant um but but thank
God I said yes that was back
during the series a um and then spent
the better part of the next few years
running the campaigns all over the US to
legalize Uber and ride sharing and the
thing that we figured out that really
worked um not unlike in some way some of
the same sentiments I think you you've
tapped into over the years which is we
were a tiny little Tech startup taxi was
a very big muscular politically
connected industry but what we realize
is our customers could become our
biggest Advocates and every time
basically the same Playbook ever we show
up in a City Taxi would get upset they'd
lean on their politician friends we
would get a season assist letter we
would ignore set this letter build up as
much of a customer base as we could the
threats from government would get
stronger and stronger and then we would
turn on the customer base and say okay
if you like this thing and want to keep
it you need to text email tweet call
whatever it is this particular elected
official and the way it really worked
was we could do it all through the app
right which is ultimately what led to
the mobile voting stuff that I'm doing
and that worked and we beat taxi and and
um did the process again with clear to
get them into airports took Equity that
worked and then met my partner Jordan
knf who run who's running blackstone's
internal Venture fund at the time and
the question we started asking is if you
truly understand regulation and you can
truly do something about it how much of
a better investor does that make you 10%
20% 30% and and we didn't know the
answer you should know that I mean
traditional venture capitalist try and
steer clear of EXA so we we run towards
what everyone else runs away from which
has both been good and bad it's been
good in that when it comes to deal flow
returns for our investors all of that
really good because I have a monopoly in
this tiny little space and the reality
is most businesses are regulated one way
or another by government so they're
going to run into issues um it's bad
because it made raising the first couple
of funds really hard right because hey
guys we're about to just run into
whatever the yeah and do something
totally different than ever like like
regulatory Thicket you we're going to
run into it right and because of my
training in politics you know I was used
to the like this is new and different
and bigger and better than ever kind of
like that was my sales pitch and it
turns out what like institutional
investors want to hear is this is
exactly like what you've always done
with this tiny risk-free twist right and
it took me years to sort of figure out
how to sort of adapt to that um now that
we're out there raising our fourth fund
um it's a little easier because we've
sort of proven out the model we continue
to have a monopoly in our little space
but um we're kind of a unique Venture
fund so we invest in seeden series a
startups the same kind of people you you
dealt with when you started um and we
ask all the same usual stuff how big is
the market what's the founder like what
do we think of the idea but then we ask
two more questions that usually are not
asked one is is there a getting
regulatory issue or opportunity that if
it were solved could really Drive growth
and valuation and if so can we solve it
and when the answer is yes to both
that's really Mak sense for us to invest
like the first deal we ever did was
FanDuel ran all the campaigns to fantasy
sports betting holy crap was was that a
good deal then cuz like I I literally it
worked out really well and using FanDuel
like I bet out an NBA game last that
worked out I I mean we're actually long
on once this company goes public once
the lock Up's over we're out but but it
went really well um and so we're
literally running Regulatory and
political campaigns for our portfolio
companies to legalize whatever new idea
it is and it could be something that
already exists like taxis or sports
betting um but could also be things like
cryptocurrency or flying cars or
autonomous trucks or delivery drones or
whatever it is I remember that Uber
campaign where everyone's like hey tell
your local uh officials that you love
this thing and the fact is we all did
love it because we're like oh my gosh
you know this is vastly superior to yes
whatever the heck yeah uh and you so you
had proof of concept now you named a
bunch of things uh that might be uh
skirmishing with Regulators upcoming are
you invested in things that you can talk
about where you can say hey guys like
here are some of the things that we're
we're not in any flying car companies um
although I have to say when I started
working on this it was like here's a
cool Fantastical concept Y and that
industry has evolved really fast and
three years later I would say that they
are sort of vying with autonomous cars
now to sort of be the first mover so it
has I didn't expect that to happen it's
pretty cool and as a result we have been
looking at some deals we haven't done
one I don't think it fits our investment
profile because it's so Capital
intensive that it's probably not the
right kind of deal for us um but yeah
you know so one of our biggest spaces is
in digital health and the thing that
it's hard to say Co was ever good but
one thing where Co actually had a silver
lining is it introduced people to the
concept of of digital Health where you
can sort of talk to a medical
professional over some sort of
electronic device um and get your care
that way and not surprising if you can
do it in a much easier way than it used
to be before people prefer that right
and so U we've got lots of investments
in that space so like one company's
called Roman it's it's a men's health
company um and for them we had to
legalize prescription via text um
because you know first doctors wanted
the medical boards want you have to go
in person then they kind of relented to
video but the the idea that Zach Tano
the founder of Roman had was If people
could asynchronously receive care be a
freaking huge value ad you know exactly
and so there's that
um one of our best investments Alma
they're a company that basically is the
business in a box for therapists so
therapists are kind of two things at the
same time one is the thing they want to
be which is mental health professionals
and two is the thing they don't want to
be which are small business owners and
yet they're both and what Alma built was
the software where takes care of all the
insurance all the billing all the
scheduling all the pain in the ass stuff
but the regulatory battle has been
allowing doctors in one state to treat
patients in another state cross state
licens well don't don't you know that
people's brains are totally different
across St lines oh yeah a Kansas brain a
Nebraska brain totally different um it's
protectionism right obviously from the
State Medical boards and so we've been
fighting that off and so yeah there
there's a lot in digital Health but but
ftech gaming Transportation you know
we're in lots of different
sectors this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com yangang today
that's e p s
vpn.com yangang and you can get an extra
3 months free expressvpn.com
gang
congratulations man I mean you're you're
pushing the envelope and some people
might hear that and say oh but then when
you talk about the use cases it's like
clearly everyone would be better off if
you could get prescriptions uh you know
like the way we communicate now I mean
the younger generation they they don't
want to pick up the phone much less see
you in
person I mean like if they're going to
get uh what they need I I think uh that
kind of innovation makes perfect sense
so you talked about flying cars because
that is the main narrative in your new
novel obvious in hindsight um and and so
it seems far out that there's this
flying car company that wants to uh make
it okay to fly cars and New York City or
Austin or wherever it is and I got to
say the book is very much a love letter
uh to New York City uh New York City is
kind of a character in the book I'd yeah
yeah absolutely I a little bit because
so a couple years ago um you know Howard
wolson right yeah Howard and I started
this thing called the Gotham book prize
um where every year we give out a
$50,000 prize to the best book either
about New York City or set in New York
City that year um and as a result I
think I've just just as a judge I've
read so many books uh that I think it it
got entrenched in my head and obviously
my book is uh not winning any prizes but
um but nonetheless I think that kind of
helped me turn turn your into a
character well it it shows man it's like
that this book is a love letter to New
York City but uh it's also a fascinating
inside look to how the heck you try and
make an innovation uh
legal and and so um before we started
recording you were talking about the
Genesis of this project where it started
out and by the way it reads very much
like a movie um screenplay in part
because that's kind of it it started out
as a TV series or probably it did so um
Steven Soderberg the director of traffic
and Aaron Brockovich otions 11 and all
these various movies he's won Academy
Awards for you have this a sort of trend
where celebrities like to buy liquor
companies I did notice that yes so
Stephen bought a brandy company based in
Bolivia and then ran some regulatory
issues because a alcohol heavily
regulated B importation heavily
regulated C Bolivia is a communist
country with whom we have no diplomatic
relations so he needed a in order to
just Market the product in the way he
wanted to Market it we needed a federal
rule change so Stephen and I had a
mutual friend we got into introduced
started working together on this and
then when the galley from my first book
The fixer came out I handed it to him
and said hey just wrote this would love
your opinion on it he said okay I'm
flying to London tonight I'm going to
read on the plane I wake up the next
morning and there's an email from
Stephen saying we got to make this a TV
show um so I start playing around with
concepts of like what would a
fictionalized version of that look like
um and at the time it was like well
flying cars is a sort of Fantastical
futuristic concept let's make it about
that and uh I wrote The Pilot he heon
and I wrote it together I wrote the next
nine scripts we started pitching it our
big meeting with Apple TV was set from
March 10th 2020 of course Co came
meeting never happened uh Stephen moved
on to other stuff but I liked the
concept so much that I felt like I still
want I didn't want to just let it sort
of fall apart sure so I converted into a
novel well I I got to say the
craftsmanship in this novel is really
evident as is the time uh the the heart
um and that explains it actually because
it sounds like what you did is you had
this entire multi-episode script yeah
and then that ended up getting
incorporated into the novel yeah and
look ultimately if you look at the
original scripts and the novel they
ended up being pretty different in some
ways um and in some way novel as we were
talk about this before we started
recording writing Fiction's really hard
yeah uh and so um but but yeah I it I
think that it just sort of gave me
enough of a framework that I was able to
to do it the hardest thing was to sort
of let go of some characters and some
plot lines right because you know the
fun thing about working in politics in
real life is like crazy happens all
the time by definition which makes it
hard but also Al interesting and in some
ways I didn't I mean the book
exaggerates reality a little bit but but
not really that much yeah I I think it
felt pretty accurate to me honestly so
uh so let's talk about a little bit uh
it's about uh flying car startup and
it's somewhat aggressive Ecentric
CEO and then the engineers that are
making it work behind the scenes and
firewall this uh comms firm that they
hire to try and run the campaign to to
make it legal they they start pitting
cities against each other they're like
hey Austin don't you want to be the
flying car city hey New York which by
like a lot of this did rig very very
true to me um so uh talk a little bit
about uh like the the characters and
what you were trying to aside from a
very very true to life sense of how this
process actually works yeah sure so um
so the book as you said it's about a
campaign to legalize flying cars in New
York Los Angeles and Austin on one side
is Flight Deck the flying car startup
and their vicious political Consultants
called firewall um and then the other
side is Uber the Autobon Society the
Socialist the transit workers and the
Russian mop um and while you know the
books are obviously a little bit
exaggerated just to make it fun to read
the real thing I wanted to get across is
just how decisions are really made in
Tech and in politics right um and
fundamentally the thing that I learned
from the first 20 years I spent directly
working in government and politics is
every policy output is is the result of
a political input every politician with
a few exceptions here and there but
basically every politician makes every
decision solely based on the next
election and nothing else and if they
believe that doing what you want can
help them when their next election or
not doing what you want could cost them
their next election they will work with
you and if you can't prove one of those
two things you are irrelevant and so
what I wanted in the book was all the
different politicians in the book to be
making their decisions along those lines
right um to try to give the readers a
sense of look you may like you may want
the world to work in a certain way but
this is how it actually works and if you
understand it then maybe you can do
something about it yeah I I think that's
the main lesson I got from the book is
this gritty uh sense of how things
happen in real life and there's almost
this Outside Inside narrative where it's
like the outside would be like hey we're
delivering this policy because it's
great for consumers like did you see the
recent talk from Bill Gurley like that
yes was that talks about this that that
it's that there's actually this
unfortunately this real regulatory
capture I learned some of this from you
I also learned some of this from from uh
your book um about just how much of a
knife fight it is behind the scenes to
to figure out which policy wins yeah and
it's interesting so Bill and then Mark
andreon wrote I I haven't read it yet
but I know he wrote sort of like a tech
Utopia no regulation screed recently um
and and on one hand you know they're
both much better VCS than I am but I
kind identified that with them because
I'm I'm trying to be like them I guess
um on one
hand it is really rough to sort of
figure out how do you take down an
entrenched interest or if it's a brand
new technology like you know um uh
psilocybin legalization right like there
is no regulatory framework right so what
should it be um so it's a big fight both
with other startups with entrenched
interests um you know with Regulators I
think the prevailing view in Tech that
all regulation is bad is not correct
right um and you obviously understand
the Nuance of all this you know
regulation is n in my view neither
inherently good nor bad um it's just a
question of what the regulation is how
it's applied and if it's applied to sort
of further the best interest of
consumers that's great uh regulatory
capture which we mened before is usually
when the entrenched interest who is not
particularly serving consumers well like
the taxi industry have developed so much
political power that the Regulators end
up just protecting them as opposed to
looking out for the voters and the
constituents and the consumers and all
of that and so you know in my day job of
sort of investing in startups and then
trying to help their political issues um
you know there's a mix of trying to
figure out what regulations do we need
to allow the business to succeed but
what are also regulations that will
allow the industry to succeed long term
that will protect consumers like just
sort of getting over on somebody like
you know it's it might work for a year
or two but at the end of the day if you
want a sustainable long-term sector in
industry it's got to work for everyone
um and a lot of our job is figuring that
out hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you yeah Uber is a great example because
Uber is something that solved a real
problem and consumers loved it uh and so
then if you put it up to you know public
opinion everyone was like oh yeah know
let's make that happen now to be clear
there were entrenched interest Taxi
companies where the value of their
medallions um you know suffered as a
result and and that that's uh that's
rough but you don't want to curb
Innovation because you could apply that
kind of lens to like a lot of different
situations uh and the the question is
where do you draw the lines you hope
that you have political figures that are
actually mindful of like the the
tradeoffs but unfortunately right now
the answer to whoever can get in their
ear with the fact look you you come this
way so you guys did something that at
the time was like a massive innovation
was like it was highly unusual to appeal
to the public right but it was the only
way to so if you take the political
input shape policy outputs it was the
only way to do it right so if we just
assume the Baseline nature of Politics
as it is not as we'd like it to be
you're a city council member in Tulsa
Oklahoma taxi guys give you two grand
per campaign cycle in return for the two
grand you do what they want right I just
had 4,000 people from your District
tweet text email call and all these ways
tell you leave this alone I love this
thing right and as a result the input
shifted from sure for the two grand I'll
do what the taxi guys want to there's no
way that I'm going to do what
the taxi guys want and piss off all of
these constituents in my district um we
change the inputs or like FanDuel is a
good example too where you know I S
remember the conversations we would have
with like a state rep in Alabama
wherever it is and would be like pretty
simple like look you have
3,214 FanDuel draftking customers in
your District let's be honest they don't
know who you are they probably don't
even know what a State Rep is but they
love fantasy sports betting and
if you take this away from them we are
going to register every one of them to
vote we're going to tell them that
you're the one that did it and we're
going to bring them to the poll to vote
against you in the next election and you
know every politici America said I don't
need that problem and we were able to
legalize it one way or another
everywhere so it's it's inputs and
outputs so the the subject in a lot of
people's minds right now which is near
and dear to me is uh AI I'm sure some of
the companies that you're investing in
sure um utilize AI in various ways uh
and there is you know concern or a
certain public appetite for some kind of
uh
regulatory um framework or even agency
or organ uh that doesn't seem to be
coming from DC in part because they're
looking up saying hey guys you know like
there last I checked there were over a
half dozen different proposals so no one
knows yeah like one of my jokes is like
if you have 10 proposals you have no
proposals is what's happening um do you
have a viewpoint on the um adoption of
AI in terms of things you're excited
about and yeah sure so I I've got I've
kind of got a Viewpoint of it as a
venture capitalist and then as kind of a
a political hack or whatever you want to
call me um so my fun the way we see AI
is it's not even that it's a specific
category it is a tool that every one of
our portfolio companies should at least
be asking themselves if it could be
useful to them um and we have a lot of
companies that we don't call AI
companies but they're using AI to
perform their underlying function so Cod
zodiac which is an autonomous Trucking
Company the autonomous Trucking is done
by artificial intelligence elaborate
which is a company that produces takes
those incomprehensible lab reports you
get from your doctor and turns into
really easy to read infographics that's
done by AI the contract Network which
can you can basically say hey I want a
contract around this and then it could
almost create it for you with all the
industry comps and everything else sort
of automatically that's AI now we don't
call any of those AI companies um but I
think that outside of the one category
generative AI it's something that we're
going to see in everything and from a
regulatory standpoint you know there's
two different ways that you have to look
at the first would be these companies
are still subject to all the lots of
existing laws that govern their behavior
right um Lena Khan who runs the FTC and
I did an event here at this bookstore
that we're at right now a couple months
ago and she said like you know yes we're
going to need AI laws but the reality is
most of these companies are already
covered by existing regulations and laws
they just have to comply with them so
that that's true um the other thing
though is you know by definition
regulation lags Innovation right if the
bureaucrats that make the rules could
instead be Tech Founders coming up with
brilliant ideas and making millions of
dollars they would do that right they
can so the founder has to sort of come
up with it first um and so I don't think
we know yet exactly what AI regulation
needs to look like I will say this there
are existing policy proposals out there
around teac like repealing section 230
or having some sort of us version of
gdpr a privacy framework for data that I
think would actually get out a lot of
the potential problems caused by Ai and
while it's great that people in Congress
are throwing together proposals you know
we should repealed section 230 15 years
ago you know so like we haven't even
done the internet you know 2.0
regulation let alone internet 3.0 you
know I mean what's funny is like you
built your career uh in in politics and
then now you're kind of this strange
hybrid you're like
blade yeah I I I I guess I kind of pick
at any give moment what I want to be
right yeah so we're sitting in a podcast
studio in a bookstore that's kind of
Another Love Letter to to New York can
you talk a little bit because now I one
of the things I said is like like you
said something to me where someone can
actually just use his podcast yeah free
um so I opened up so I mentioned the the
Gotham book prize and I was really
enjoying kind of working with authors
and had you know I've always L books and
I read a crazy amount and I always
thought like one day when I retired or
something it'd be fun to own a bookstore
and then when Co hit and the city lost
600,000 jobs my view is you know what
Bradley you're going to lose money
whenever you do this um and luckily you
can afford to lose money you might as
well start losing money now now right um
but you know as a result so you can do
something nice for New York from a
retail standpoint which is open up uh a
store and hire you know a dozen people
and they are on the same Healthcare that
the people my Venture Capital fund gets
um and create this community resource
like do it at a time when the city is
hurting right A lot of the same logic on
a much smaller scale that led you to
choose to run for mayor right the city
is hurting and you knew that you have
been able to sort of help bring it back
um and this Administration confirms that
every single day um so um I started
looking into it and I wanted it to be
somewhere downtown and I we found this
spot on Orchard between H Stanton and my
grandparents when they came and my dad
when they came to this country from the
refugee camps in Europe after World War
II um my grandfather and a guy he knew
from the camp started a 300 foot sweater
store on Allen Street called p&t netwar
and so I texted my dad and said I'm
about to sign a lease where was that
store cuz I knew it was around here
somewhere and he told me I'm like that's
the next block and he's like yeah and I
said what was it called and he said pnt
knitwear and then he texted but you
can't name a bookstore p&t knitwear so
of course the store is named uh p&t
knitwear we are a bookstore um we are
the only podcast studio uh that I know
of at least in New York York maybe
anywhere that just anyone can use for
free just come on our
website yep you want to use it we are
happy to have you um we are an event
space both at the Lower Side Community
and literary community and again if
you're a lower side organization we give
it to you for free so just let us know
um and a cafe and so it's um it's really
lovely guys you got to check it out if
you're in the area yeah it's it's it's
been great clearly not the best way to
make money but I really enjoy
it
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yang this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now you know I mean it's a labor of love
uh and one of the things that's wild
about you man is that you're like hyper
smart and commercial but you also have a
lot of heart I mean you you do a lot of
things because you know that they're the
right thing to do certainly uh your work
in Mobile voting which I freaking love
yeah um is just because you think it's
going to be better for the future I I
don't see a world so so if you get back
to a couple things that we've been
saying right so the thing I learned in
all my time in politics and I did city
government state government federal
government executive branch legislative
branch I'm a lawyer like I've seen this
from pretty much every angle yeah it's
that while there are exceptions you
would be one if you were in office my
was certainly won um policy outputs
result from political inputs right and
so if you want to make things better it
has to be in the interest of that
politician to do so and then we did Uber
the same people who don't know who their
state senator is they never vote in a
city council primary were taking the
time to advocate for us because a it was
something they cared about and B we made
it really easy right you could do it
right from the app and so when that
happened and we're thinking like holy
if people could vote this way maybe
turn out would be a lot higher and then
over the succeeding years cloud and
blockchain Technology both got better
and better um and so in 2018 I started
funding elections in different states um
we either deployed military people with
disabilities were voting in real
elections on their phone um we did s
States 21 jurisdictions they were all
audited by national cyber security
Center all came back clean turn on an
average doubled city of Denver did a
poll of the people who participated 100%
not surprisingly said they prefer it
because to your point before about like
getting a prescription you know online
is supposed to happen to go somewhere um
but the cyber security Community
especially the people who are just
obsessed with paper ballots I'm sure you
you've come across them this is the the
disingenuousness man it's like you say
hey why don't we vote over the internet
on our mobile phones be like oh it's not
secure and you can show them 20 20
things being like it's perfectly secure
demos and the rest of it but the truth
is they just don't want us to be able to
vote that way no they they don't want
more turnout yeah I mean they like
things the way they are if if turnout
gets too high there's a the mobile
voting book that I mentioned that I just
wrote that one of the chapters opens
with you know Abner Mikvah was no I
don't so Abner Mikvah was uh federal
judge he was Clinton's White House
Council um I took his class in law
school at the University of Chicago um
and sort of this just famous sort of
Chicago Legend and in like 19 I don't
know 48 or whatever it was he's a young
man and he walks into the adeli
Stevenson for President office in
Chicago and says I'd like to volunteer
and like award BOS I think was Timo
Sullivan sort of takes a hit off a scar
and says who sent you and he said nobody
and Sullivan said we don't want nobody
that nobody sent and I think M actually
named one of his books that and but
that's still the reality today right
which is they don't want the reason they
do Jerry mandering the reason they
schedule elections and dates that are
hard to vote out they restrict access is
they want to control the electorate and
they especially don't want gen Z and gen
Alpha when they come up age voting
because they're going to be held
accountable for all kinds of problems
that they've let fester and and let get
out of control and so I think that the
the bad news about politicians is
they'll do whatever they have to do to
stay in office the good news is they'll
do whatever they have to do to stay in
office so when turnout is 12% let's say
you're a republican congressman from
Florida um and turn out 12% in your
primary half of those members half of
those voters are NRA members you know
intellectually that it's crazy that
someone can walk into a store and walk
out with an AK-47 but you also know that
should you ever say that you're done uh
there's a congressman from upstate New
York in the Buffalo area and Chris
Jacobs who's a republican super Trumper
but there was if you might remember this
a mass shooting a supermarket in Buffalo
and he sort of said we we need to look
at some of these laws he you know he's
really shaken by
they immediately stripped the line from
him so he couldn't run in the next
election and his career ended or take
you know New York Tech example Amazon
did this headquarter competition hq2
which is I kind of stole a little bit of
that strategy in in the novel yeah and
they picked New York which was great and
they picked uh Long Island City which is
a district that that you got to know and
the polling showed that the majority of
the district wanted it a majority of the
city wanted it but turn out in that
primary is typically like 14% I got a
Mike janys who's a very smart politician
but a politician through and through
understood that that 14% hated Amazon
hated Jeff Bezos hated Tech hated big
business and that he would be punished
politically if he let the deal go
through and so he is the guy that led
the fight I mean AOC did this too but
really Jer did it on a state level is
the guy that led the fight to to kill
the bill he picked one job his own over
40,000 jobs why because those 14% would
be you know IDE right but now let's just
sort of say people can vote in their
phones and turn out that Republican
primary and and genero's primary both
36% so still like a third just based on
the math and based on the polling the
Republican would have to be for an
assault weapons ban because that's what
the majority of his voters would want
jys would have to be for the Amazon
headquarters that's the majority of hit
voters would want and so if we want
things to get done we have to sort of
get more and more people voting and the
only election that really matters is the
primary because of Jerry mandering and
the only way I think to increase primary
turnout at scale is to let people do it
securely on their phones yeah and as
usual you put your money or your mouth
is anyone who wants to can go to Mobil
voting.org uh Bradley's been working on
it for years and we are conspiring to
make it a reality that's how we're going
to unlock a ton of good for people this
book was I got to say man you've done a
lot of impressive in your career
and this book actually is right up there
because I was reading it and and this
you know I came with a novel recently
and I'm sure some people are reading it
be like oh you know
like you know it's like oh um why why is
uh you know this person writing a novel
like this novel is actually important
you know like if people read this they
will have a much firmer grasp of how
stuff is happening it's entertaining
it's Lively it reads like it should be
on Apple TV honestly I hope people check
out obvious in hindsight because you'll
be entertained but you'll also learn a
lot about how things work and sometimes
don't work yeah well Andrew thanks for
for saying that thanks for the podcast
and for all the different things you do
you know I found a bunch of ways toward
together and uh mobile voting is just
the next one mobile voting obvious in
hindsight Bradley Tusk can't wait to see
what you do next my friend thank you
thanks for me
[Music]
out